here's a story from mediaite Trump calls
on states to deploy National Guard to
Texas as state clashes with federal
government over border crisis there's a
lot to break down here but I will jump
straight to Trump's statement his first
portion of the statement when I was
President we had the most secure Border
in history Joe Biden has surrendered our
border and is aiding and abetting a
massive invasion of millions of illegal
migrants into the United States instead
of fighting to protect our country from
this Onslaught Biden is unbeliev
fighting to tie the hands of Governor
Abbott and the state of Texas so that
the invasion continues unchecked in the
face of this National Security Public
Safety and public health catastrophe
Texas has rightly invoked The Invasion
Clause of the Constitution and must be
given full support to repel The Invasion
page two we encourage all willing states
to deploy their guards to Texas to
prevent the entry of illegals and to
remove them back across the border all
Americans should support the the common
sense measures by Texas authorities to
protect the safety security and
sovereignty of Texas and of the American
people when I am president on day one
instead of fighting Texas I will work
hand inand with Governor Abbott and
other border states to stop The Invasion
seal the border and rapidly begin the
largest domestic deportation operation
in history those Biden has let in should
not get comfortable because they will be
going home now the big news here is that
we actually have
it's the number is much bigger than this
but there is a report 25 States
Republican governors of 25 states have
signed a letter backing Texas now the
number is actually larger than this by
now but things are changing so rapidly
it's hard to know exactly how many
states have already joined in and
needless to
say look guys I I can't believe this is
the headline we're writing obviously
everyone's trying to be a little light
on how they describe this mediaite is
just saying Trump calls on states to
deploy National Guard as the state
clashes with the federal government but
Trump's entire statement is how Joe
Biden and the federal government is
aiding and abetting illegal immigrants
by calling on the National Guard of
willing states to deploy to Texas he is
calling for these states to act in
absolute Defiance of federal Authority
at a time when the Biden Administration
has given an a deadline to Texas Friday
is the day you must back off your guards
or else
the question then becomes or else
what I I have a million thoughts on
these as through you we were all talking
about this off the air and so that the
thoughts I could go on and on about it
but let let's be clear Joe Biden is
committing treason and he didn't just
start committing treason Biden and his
administration when you take over as
president and you defy the immigration
law when it's your job as president to
execute the law that is treasonous they
didn't fall they didn't stumble they
didn't Bumble they didn't fail they
didn't whoopsy the Communists who now
run this country got elected and opened
up the border on purpose because it is
the ultimate win for them that
Republicans cannot and will not reverse
you flood the country with illegals you
destroy the country and that's what they
want but it's sedition I would argue not
treason treason would be aiding and
abetting an enemy whereas this is just
actively trying to destroy the country
they are enemies they are our enemies
country is being filled by our enemies
Chinese Russian many others theying
there are some if if an invading force
from China marched through Mexico and
Biden facilitated their Invasion that's
arguably treason but legally the
question that becomes are we actively at
war with China because that's basically
what treason is it's when you side with
the Enemy a bunch of random people from
a bunch of random countries coming to
this country Biden facilitating that I
would say is a seditious conspiracy
basically seeking to undermine our
system of governance destroying it from
within well we we look we can split here
as about sedition or treason it doesn't
really matter he committed a crime as
president of the United States of
America this is a crime a crime that
actually should not result in
impeachment it should result in
impeachment and Joe Biden spending the
rest of his life whatever that length
that may be in federal prison and if we
were interested in Saving this country
Joe Biden and many people in his
administration would be going to prison
sadly we're more than 3 years into the
Biden presidency and we're just now
getting some kind of real effort to bind
against this now that we're 8 million
illegals heavier in the country that's
on top of the what 30 million million
were already here but they did this on
purpose that's the most that's the thing
that people have such a hard time
digesting especially the norms and
normas out there this wasn't an accident
and the media will will play that up
they'll even call these people migrants
all day long now that's the newest thing
you got to make them yeah we got to make
them sound like geese going south for
the winter when they're not at all
they're illegals they're all criminals
the men are the criminals the women are
the criminals the children are criminals
behind them and they should all be
thrown out of the country immediately
the legal term is Criminal Alien well
you call them whatever you want they're
criminals the academic term and and well
well this is why you get you Nikki Haley
saying oh they're not criminals like no
no this is a legal term I'm not saying
that to disrespect anybody it's a legal
term they are criminal aliens yeah every
every one of them and every one of them
violated our national sovereignty and we
have so poisoned patriotism in this
country that now everyone on the left
and half the people on the right somehow
think we're supposed to be America's
open seore and we're not supposed or the
world's open seore where you just dump
everyone you want no we are a sovereign
country with a culture we are a unique
people we're not a Melting Pot we're not
it's not multiculturalism we have a
unique uh culture in this country that
is wonderful and should be preserved and
protected I'm glad we finally have
somebody doing something about it and I
applaud the governors we'll see if they
can actually hold out but at least
someone's doing something so we have
people asking us to break down sedition
versus treason so I will Cornell Law
School defines uh uh I should I should
say they don't Define they show us the
actual us code 18 us code 2384 Sous
conspiracy if two or more persons in any
state or territory or any place subject
to the jurisdiction of the United States
conspire to overthrow put down or to
destroy by force the government destroy
by force the government of the United
States or to Levy war against them or to
oppose by force the authority thereof or
by force to prevent hinder or delay the
execution of any law of the United
States or by forced to seize take or
possess any property of the United
States contrary to the authority thereof
they shall each be fined under this
title or imprison not more than 20 years
or both treason specifically is whoever
owing allegiance to the United States
levies war against them or aderes to
their enemies giving them Aid and
comfort within the United States or
elsewhere is guilty of treason and shall
suffer death or shall be imprisoned not
less than 5 years and that's a big gap
right there and find it at this title so
I would argue specifically the Biden
Administration is engaged in a seditious
conspiracy they are committing crimes
against the country country to damage
and destroy the fabric of this country
in violation of numerous state laws as
well as federal laws whereas treason
would be uh uh declaring war against the
unit adhering to war against the United
States so typically when this has been
debated in the past treason has been
typically applied to if we were like
let's say at the formation of the
Marines the barber Pirates if someone in
the United States sided with the Pirates
that's treason you're a traitor a
traitor is siding With the Enemy in
active conflict sedition means Joe Biden
his buddy got together and said let's
engage in a plan that subverts the law
and destroys this country by force then
to be sedition yeah I I I believe it's
seditious conspiracy that's look all
that's fine with me convict him of
shoplifting for all I care just send him
to prison whatever it's fine whatever
he's doing as president and look we all
know we're not talking about Joe Biden
we're not talking about the kadaver
who's pretending to be president we're
talking about the filthy commies that he
surrounds himself with this is all Susan
Rice and Victoria Nunes and all the
other maist who actually occup positions
of power well look Joe Biden got go but
they got to go with him they can all
share sell I'm talking about the CBP
agents I I could give a crap about Susan
Rice the Nazi guards the Nazi guards on
the border who are engage in a human
smuggling operation with a badge on
their chest that says CBP they're the
ones who should be in prison are you
serious absolutely 100% for following
orders J you like are we going to are we
going to let the Nazi guards go you
think the people who are facilitating
one of the largest human smuggling
operations this this this world has ever
seen should be just oh it's not your
fault it's some other guy's fault for
telling you to commit the crime no I
think that's ridiculous I think you're
crazy you ask a CBP agent to rob a bank
and he does you think he shouldn't go to
jail the CPP agents are retiring they're
quitting they're getting out because
because of all yeah and they should they
definitely should these these men are
doing good things so the guys the guys
so so the guys on video who are
smuggling children and engag in human
trafficking they should go to prison oh
that's fine yeah that's those are CBP
agents 100% that's fine yes agree if
you're going to take the dirty ones and
look let's be honest the the border and
I have many friends on Border Patrol
border patrol agents have always been I
don't want to say susceptible but
they've been in a unique position to be
corruptible because of the amount of
money that crosses the Border because of
the drugs and human smuggling I mean I
have many close friends in there whose
friends are in federal prison now why
they were busted taking bribes from the
cartel bribes of money bribes of women
things like that so that's really common
that kind of bribery at the border of
Border guards oh they'll send you you
can uh There Are Places many many places
across our Southern border pick your
place pick a place in Arizona where the
border patrol stretch so thin you'll
have a little stretch of Border where
there's one dude maybe two dudes man in
the post cartel guys run a couple
high-end hookers up there for a night
you uh enjoy yourself next thing you
know you turn the other way for two
hours and they've got the people across
they want to get across now this is not
all of them by any stretch of the
imagination but it happens and yeah you
can send those guys to prison with Biden
but listen those are also guys who is
who is most responsible for the
atrocities in history yeah the nkvd
sucked yeah there was really bad throw
them all in prison they weren't given
the orders right it was starling when
you have evil people in charge giving
orders to open up the Border then those
are the people who have to be punished
the most severe in any society but
doesn't a man owe something to his own
heart and soul like don't you owe your
to yourself to follow a moral code oh
for sure and so if you don't like you're
evil too you're evil too if you're
standing there at aitz just like letting
people so there's no question about it
but you're not the height of evil you're
not the one the problem in the country
is our leaders you have it totally
backwards the homeless guy
meaning and and he would never chared
with you're allowed to stand in in an
alley in order people to do everything
they won't do it but if a man in a if a
homeless man in an alley looks to a
police officer and says you should go in
there and rob a bank and the cop goes
you got it who do we arrest do we arrest
the homeless guy no we arrest the guy
who robbed the bank you know who never
we who we never arrest in this country
politicians that's who we never arrest
border patrol agents get arrested dirty
cops arrested a dir cops get arrested
Ians never go to prison in this country
FBI agents never go to prison in this
country CIA never goes to prison
in had we definitely had what they are
now those AR politician FBI and C what
I'm saying is people in positions of
power in this country never ever ever go
to prison in fact they don't even fear
going to prison we had an FBI agent lie
on a document to get a fisa warrant so
he could spy on Donald Trump he didn't
even get disbarred Kevin Klein Smith
didn't even get disbarred that human
being should never see the light of day
again ever get this and the people who
are giving the orders should also go to
prison but the most culpable element of
the human smuggling operation are the
human Smugglers absolutely not
absolutely not the American not the
human Smugglers the American president
is more responsible for human smuggling
than the human smugg the cartel is less
responsible for human smuggling than
Biden than Joe Biden himself because Joe
Biden is the one inviting them in Joe
Biden is the leader in the well forget
about Joe Biden we're talking about the
Biden Administration the United States
federal government is the most criminal
government in the western hemisphere all
you're arguing is that you like some
human Smugglers not others thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net